hello
my name is dan bastian and i'm a 40-year
cancer survivor
from osteogenic sarcoma before i get
into my story though
i want to thank the canines and kids
foundation pause for a cure
and the rally foundation for the
incredible work that they're doing
to fight against pediatric cancer and
for the veterinarians and physicians
that are now
collaborating together to expedite the
research
so we can find a cure for this disease
i was diagnosed march 8 1980.
i checked all the boxes i was a boy
15 years old playing lots of sports
very athletic and i was going through a
big growth spurt
i was having a lot of knee pain after
practice and my father finally sent me
for an x-ray
i basically went from that x-ray table
to a hospital room
in a whirlwind i was told
that the tumor in my femur had eaten
through
the bone and then i had approximately
six months to live
now imagine that you're 15 years old
not a care in the world and you're told
you have six months to live
i don't know how my parents did it
i don't know how my eight brothers and
sisters did it
when i got to memorial sloan kettering i
met my oncologist dr jerry rosen
incredible human being he explained the
protocol that they were going to use for
me
and i don't know if it's a good thing or
a bad thing but it's still used today
high dose methotrexate gliomycin cytoxan
decamycin and adriamycin the red devil
why is it called the red devil again
imagine being 15 years old
lying in a hospital bed while you have
an iv hooked up to you and they're
injecting this red liquid
into your veins at the same time
an adult is standing over you with
paddles
to resuscitate you to bring you back
after your heart stops
when this medicine hits your bloodstream
it's an unbelievable memory that
unfortunately i'll never forget
and that's why it's called the red devil
but thanks to god
to my brothers and sisters and my
parents and the great doctors and nurses
i'm still here today they would not let
me quit
they made me keep fighting on for 10
months i went through the chemotherapy
i went through the surgery the limb
salvage surgery
to try to save my leg and after 10
months
it was over i thought we had won
the battle against osteogenic sarcoma
was done
at least i thought so i wasn't planning
on the adriamycin laying dormant
in my system for about 20 years
and then coming back to life and eating
my heart muscle
causing cardiomyopathy
my ejection fraction went down to 16. no
wonder i was so tired
my cardiologist finally figured out a
combination of different drugs to use
and with those drugs as of last month my
injection fracture is now
52 but back in the beginning of that
i was told i need to go on a heart
transplant list
after everything else now a heart
transplant
thanks to the osteogenic sarcoma
that wasn't the only problem that i had
i had 18 surgeries over the 10 years
after i was diagnosed
trying to save my leg i was in constant
pain
constantly in surgery and i had no
quality of life
i opted to have my leg amputated above
the knee
in 1990 when i was 25 years old i was a
systems programmer for ibf
ibm at the time and six weeks after
surgery
i was then mountain biking that winter i
was downhill skiing
in the spring i started golfing again
and in the summer i was water skiing
i started doing volunteer work with
memorial sloan kettering
meeting with kids are going to be losing
their limb
to osteogenic sarcoma
showing them video footage of me doing
these different things and showing them
that their life isn't over
i went home and i quit my job at ibm
i went back to school and got my degree
in prosthetics did my residency at
newington children's hospital
and i opened progressive orthotics and
prosthetics about 20 years ago
now diabetes is the number one cause of
amputation
but unfortunately i'm still seeing
pediatric cases
from osteogenic sarcoma one comes to
mind
and will never leave my heart her name
was belinda she was 12 years old
right above the knee amputee osteogenic
sarcoma
and i gave her eulogy two months ago
i never want to have to do that again
one of the hardest things i've ever had
to do in my life
this beautiful little girl smart
amazing and she passed away
she had the same protocol i had and
that's why we need a cure
we need better protocols we need to do
this
we need to do this for belinda
thank you for your time and as dean
would say
rally on thank you
hi everyone um
[Music]
brett we're not seeing any video at uh
on our side i don't think oh there we
are
okay well welcome everyone dan thank you
for those uh
really very inspiring words and sharing
uh your story a lifelong story
as unfortunate it is for for so many uh
patients who are able to overcome the
primary
cancer but live with the consequences of
our treatment and that's why we're here
today
because we're all committed to looking
for better solutions and improving the
outcome
for all patients without the sarcoma to
restore everyone
to full health so we have a very uh
distinguished panel and i'm honored to
to moderate it
um we're bringing together expertise
from the regulatory side
uh from the industry side uh both
pediatric as well as veterinary
so i think we can jump right in i'm
gonna ask everyone to very briefly
uh give a sentence or two about
themselves
and then uh the questions greg let me
start with you
greg i think you still are muted
all right maybe we can jump uh greg we
didn't hear you uh
carol would you like to introduce
yourself
sure um my name is carol robertson clue
and
i uh currently uh work in
across a number of different companies
and uh
institutions academic institutions um
advising on drug development and
particularly have a background in both
um in comparative medical research
with uh about uh 25 years
27 years experience in large pharma
both on the human side as well as the
animal hull side
so i'm very dedicated to um
finding out how we can make these links
between
animals and humans particularly with the
spontaneous diseases that the animals
get
thanks carol lynn boxer
hi this is lynn i work for the center
for veterinary medicine at fda
we approve drugs for animals similar to
what our counterparts do for the
drugs for humans i particularly work on
these cell and tissue products
in the office of new animal drug
evaluation
great thank you and mark kieran
hi mark kieran i was a pediatric
neuro-oncologist at the boston
children's dana farber for 25 years
and then two years ago transition to
industry at bristol-myers squibb
really is a kind of mechanism for seeing
how to get many of the newer agents into
pediatric patients thanks mark and andy
weber over to you
hi everyone i'm andy weber i'm in
clinical research at merck
i'm currently in the clinical biomarker
group and the folks in our group are
responsible for biomarker strategy
across the early and late
oncology development programs great
thank you
and cheryl london i'm cheryl london i'm
a veterinary medical oncologist
with a phd in immunology and i've been
in the comparative
and translational oncology field for the
past 25 plus
years i'm currently the dean of
research and graduate education at the
cummings school at tufts university and
i also hold dual appointments at tufts
medical school and the tough ctsi
great and greg let's see if we
overcome the technical aspect yeah yeah
i'm back on i
i was uh kicked off but uh hopefully you
can hear me now
welcome back thank you thank you i'm
greg greenman um
i'm a pediatric oncologist uh with uh
history uh too long to
reveal um in pediatric cancer
clinical research um and for the last 10
years
have been at the fda i
currently serve as the associate
director for pediatric oncology
in the agency's oncology center of
excellence
thanks greg and i'm peter adamson i'm a
pediatric oncologist
i spent about 20 years at children's
hospital philadelphia and penn
following greg i led the children's
oncology group and less than half a year
ago i also transitioned to industry
and i'm a global head of oncology
development at sanofi
so welcome everyone um if you do have
questions for those viewing we will do
our best at the end to try to get to
them there's a
place for you to type them in but why
don't we start um
given the legislative initiatives that
have occurred and most recently the race
act
greg it was a brief overview of the race
act and what his potential impact may be
sure happy too peter thanks um the race
act uh
research acceleration for uh cure and
equity
uh for children uh was actually passed
in august of
2017 was incorporated as part of the
fda reauthorization act um
and i think it has the potential
of totally changing the landscape
for childhood cancer drug development
i say that because it
actually amends two pieces of
legislation
one of which has had dramatic effects
for pediatric drug development uh in
every clinical situation
other than cancer um as great as it is
and as important that it is uh i think
it's
worth pointing out that this uh
addresses uh
one very pivotal and important
challenge to childhood cancer drug
development but clearly
this is not the magic bullet
for all of the problems and obstacles
that we have so what the race act
does is amend um one
of the two major pieces of legislation
that
sort of govern drug development in
children
the pediatric research equity act or
pria
and the best pharmaceuticals for
children act
priya is a mandatory requirement
for sponsors to study drugs
for indications that exist or drugs that
are
developed for adult indications that
also exist in the pediatric space
orphan designated conditions
are exempted and the bpca um is a
voluntary program
um that provides a six-month
exclusivity uh to sponsors uh
uh who agreed to do pediatric studies of
new drugs generally in
indications other than the indication
for which the drug was being developed
so priya since uh it's uh triggered
by indication and since the cancers of
children and the cancers of adults
are distinct and most adult cancers
don't exist in the pediatric space
with the exception of some rare cancers
which have orphan designation
there's never been a prior requirement
for
a cancer drug for an evaluation
in children so the race act
actually amends that or changes that
and as of just this past uh
august uh any uh new active ingredient
uh
uh a uh targeted drug um and the initial
um uh application uh either new drug
application
or biologic licensing application
for a targeted drug that is developed
for an adult indication but directed at
a target
that is deemed relevant to the growth or
progression
of a childhood cancer must now
include the sponsor must now include in
their initial pediatric study plan
a description of a study
to evaluate this drug
in the pediatric population this uh
is the fundamental problem uh that uh i
think uh this uh
uh act uh will uh address uh since uh
uh the average time from first in human
to first in child studies of
oncology drugs is about six and a half
years
looking at the last 15 years experience
of fda approved drugs
and actually ranges from a couple of
months to over 20 years
so i think this will certainly
provide the opportunity for
early assessment in the pediatric
population
of potentially effective drugs
so there were requirements as part of
this
statute for the agency the agency was
required to work with the national
cancer institute
in putting together a list of relevant
molecular targets um and
to publish that list um as well as
develop guidance for industry
and we did um
develop the list through a series of uh
open public meetings uh
uh with the cancer institute uh with
international content uh experts uh um
and uh um utilized a number of
sources primarily publicly available
databases the tcga the saint jude
pediatric cancer genome project the
target database
and the inform database uh peer-reviewed
published literature um and developed a
list of
of targets uh um that uh
we utilized a framework to sort of
define uh relevance
as whether there were reports of
an association between a specific target
and a known childhood cancer what that
target function was any
clinical uh evidence uh um or
pre-clinical evidence uh uh and
particularly uh
uh in pre-clin and pre-clinical models
uh
of uh pediatric tumors any adult
clinical experience
um the existence of predictive or
response
biomarkers and that
list of relevant targets is published on
the
the fda website and there's a
requirement
that we update it periodically which we
intend to do annually and there's also
an open public docket for the general
public
to suggest additions
to the list or targets that should be
deleted so our intent
was really to uh keep this as broad as
possible
um the the lists were mandated in the
statute to provide industry some
regulatory certainty
early regulatory certainty but we didn't
want it
to limit in any way the
authority or the flexibility of the
agency
in making sure that uh the appropriate
drugs
were studied uh in the neuro and in the
children
uh as early as possible so there's about
230
targets on this uh on this list
the majority of them are specific gene
uh defects are
abnormalities um the most important of
which
of course uh are the translocations uh
resulting uh
infusions and fusion oncoproteins which
are the primary drivers of a number of
the most
important pediatric cancers but
generally
there aren't drugs that are developed
since those diseases don't occur in
adults
and most of those targets have proven
undruggable
to this point in time another large
class
are those targets related to cell
lineage primarily cluster designated
antigens
and and tended uh to be uh potential
um uh targets uh for uh
immunotherapeutic uh
interventions uh targets uh not on the
tumor cells uh but on the
tumor on cells of the tumor
microenvironment uh and
the normal immune system uh and then
a whole host of others
so um as i mentioned um as
of august 18th of this year
any applicant who envisions
submitting an application for
a new drug must include in their initial
pediatric
study plan uh a description of the
study that's described as a molecularly
targeted pediatric cancer investigation
in the statute to provide
information that may be useful for
labeling
on dosing tolerability toxicity
and signal of activity we interpret that
to really be a non-hypothesis testing
dose finding studies uh looking uh for
uh signals of activity so phase one one
b
phase one two studies well great so that
that that that's that's helpful i know
there are a lot of topics i'm gonna
uh maybe shift uh because you're going
to have to respond i think to a couple
other questions
your way mark you're now an industry
veteran
what have your observations been
initially with pediatric investigation
plans in europe the implementation
of race act and now as greg said in
august with it really kicking into full
force what are you seeing and what do
you
what do you envision changing
yeah it's um you know this is not a kind
of an acute event in fact i would argue
that i got hired in
industry uh largely because of the race
for children act two years ago when
companies began recognizing
that there was a shift in the approach
for pediatrics
yeah i think what it's really had in
terms of of at least the way companies
uh um envision this process is
it means that they have to be much more
organized in terms of their pre-clinical
efforts
and i don't know if craig will talk
about some of the initiatives
through the fnih and certainly others in
europe where they're trying now to
really
collate the pre-clinical models that
would help
companies really identify the
appropriate targets and test
their early compounds since as you heard
mechanism of action
is going to be a central theme and then
i think the other thing it's forcing
companies to do is really think about
how to
organize and coordinate the pediatric
programs within companies obviously
pediatrics is a little bit of a niche
area in most companies they're not
focused for the most part on pediatrics
pediatrics is what kind of get dragged
along
as they're doing the adult stuff and so
many of them don't have it well
organized and what i've been seeing is
more and more companies now
trying to really think about how to
organize pediatrics to meet these
requirements
that in conjunction with the
pre-clinical work would allow some of
this
to go forward and meet what are now the
mandatory requirements
of race for children and thanks so
greg ideally um
when would you like to see industry come
first come forward uh you know you talk
about first in human studies
uh proof of concept but when when
ideally
would you want industry to be engaging
with regulators
specifically the fda well i think i
think as early as possible yeah and i
think
industry engagement shouldn't just
include
regulators but i think industry should
engage
early um very early um with
clinical investigators um as well uh as
as industry because i think this
is a sort of multi-uh stakeholder
decision if you will uh regarding
uh what uh target uh really is uh
relevant
um and what agents uh uh would in fact
be uh appropriate to assess early in the
pediatric population
and mark from your perspective what are
some of the internal barriers
that you think can arise
as we push these timelines earlier
well again it's mostly just that again
pediatric sense not to be the driver
and making you know having people
understand the switch
of whereas before as greg had pointed
out previously
most of what the farm industry did i
think was really based more
on kind of bpca it was looking for
exclusivity rights
by testing drugs and pediatrics that
were already approved in adults to get
patent extension
now of course you have to have done this
in advance of even getting adult
approval
and um i would say i spend as much time
if not the most amount of time
convincing people that that old
structure of
you get orphan status and and you don't
have to worry about anything and then if
you decide later
in the life cycle of a commercial drug
to do some pediatric studies to get
exclusivity that would have a financial
benefit to the company that we need to
have
the preclinical data as greg said
because i absolutely agree
you need to have worked with the
investigators both from the preclinical
side as well as from the early
translational clinical side
you need to have worked with the fda and
i have to say
that we've already had some meetings
with greg about some of the assets
moving forward to meet the new uh
requirements
and those meetings have been incredibly
helpful in terms of
guiding us making sure that we're on the
right track and it's really now a matter
of i think companies just getting used
to
what is the new reality because it is
the reality
of course you know since as you heard
the effect the
the law only took effect four weeks ago
it's not like any company has extensive
experience with it yet
but as i said we've already had our
meetings with the fda we've already
submitted
some applications under the new race for
children act and i think as each company
learns about that it will get better and
i think mostly it will awaken the
companies to the fact that they're going
to have to start taking pediatrics
more seriously thanks mark so why don't
we
shift now uh to dogs with cancer and
the potential that raised me catalyze
even greater interactions
between the veterinary oncology
community and the pediatric oncology
community um let me start maybe
briefly describe where you see the
similarities as far as the
the canine patient environment pediatric
patient environment
and to give people a foundation to to
build from
door you know i think one of the things
that's happened over the past
five years is we've generated reams of
genomic data
that have now laid the groundwork for us
to really do
some comparative study where we know
that there are similarities
across the genomic landscape and this
does then provide us an opportunity
to study upfront uh novel agents
particularly in combination in settings
which are almost impossible to do
in the current landscape of cancer
therapy which is
to interrogate novel drug combinations
they could be ios
molecule inhibitor combinations chemo
minimal combinations speaking to
some of the long-term comorbidities that
are experienced you know really working
at regiments that limit
you know upfront in patient populations
that have
never received any other treatment
before and i think
that is really where one of our
strengths lies is that we
can be innovative we can do things
really rapidly
we don't have the regulatory uh
oversight that typically
guides and sometimes slows down our
ability to be
innovative and respond rapidly uh to
things that we're seeing in our patient
population and more importantly is the
naive cajun conclusion i think there's
lots of data now accumulating it
particularly for io combinations
getting those patients up front in the
setting
of the untreated disease is more likely
to
result in positive um outcome
so you know we're flexible we we have uh
an accumulating set of tools that allows
us to do biomarker analysis
one of which is the new nano uh more
strength
canine i o panel that will allow us
really direct comparators
with a a very similar human
uh landscape so i think the tools the
resources
the flexibility uh a better
understanding of the cancers we're
treating are all going to be helpful
as we work sort of in an inner manner
with a pediatric oncologist
to help not only improve outcomes for
patients but re
reduce long-term comorbidities
uh which are really you know long-term
morbidities associated with things like
doctors and
chemotherapy really we would like to be
able to do that in partnership
very good and and cheryl i know
you spoke about regulatory flexibility
but i
there are a number of people both
pediatric oncologists and others
listening
that probably don't have a great deal of
familiarity so maybe i can ask
lynn comment a little bit about the
regulatory environment for canine
clinical trials where there's overlap
and where
there potentially is in fact greater
flexibility if you would
sure so i think there's a lot of
opportunity to develop
products for both human and animal use
and
particularly in those cases where we
have an animal that could serve as a
naturally occurring model of disease for
development of the human products
there's a there's a lot of you know
opportunity because you're if you are
using that animal
model of disease you're already
generating safety and effectiveness data
that it may be considered preclinical on
the human side but
for us that really might be the data
supporting the approval it might be akin
to that phase three study that says
you know this product works um or at
least a piece of that
data that we could use to to then get
that product approved
so having um those approved products for
the animal as well as the human you're
helping
you know twice the the population of
folks and
i think there's a lot of ways for us to
do that um
in terms of flexibility we have quite a
few programs
that can help the animal approval
process itself is a good bit different
than the human
approval process so if you're developing
products and you think there's an
opportunity and you're not familiar with
it
please come talk to us come talk to us
early so that we can let you know what
that process looks like and you can make
some decisions about you know whether or
not this is something you can do
um but it is it tends to be shorter we
don't have as many phases we don't have
time to get into all the details but
there's there are quite a few
differences
we do have various programs that can
help products get to the market a bit
faster
our conditional approval is one of those
that can apply to
drugs that are minor use minor species
which is like an orphan drug status
we also have an expanded version of that
that can apply to products for serious
and unmet needs
and that process helps you to get the
product to the market before
completing the effectiveness portion of
your approval so that's one
option there are also options for the
novel cell therapies and
potentially genomic alterations we have
a veterinary innovation program
that provides some benefits and review
process for those two so we have a
number of flexibilities built into our
system
great thanks lynn so getting back to the
canine canine cancers um
on the pediatric side of you know the
the
uh exponential growth in knowledge be it
in the biology and the genomics of
cancer
uh is continuing um and it's always more
complex than we had envisioned
maybe i can begin asking andy where are
we
in our understanding of the biology of
the genomics uh
of osteosarcoma and in particular but
other canine cancers
in general and perhaps relative to where
we may
or may not be in pediatrics
i don't think i can you know fully
answer that question yet i mean
certainly we are at that point of
developing and implementing
you know the canine models or a canine
platform per se
you know and it's critical to understand
you know just what you ask about that
translatability to various human
pediatric cancers you know what
biomarkers will
translate you know what can the canine
models
offer us that to date the mouse models
have not
right so i think you know at the same
time that we're building that knowledge
we're trying
to strengthen the connection between
you know the in vivo group pharmacology
group that's doing that
you know with the committee that
oversees all of our pediatric
uh clinical studies peter can i
can i just ask it was fascinating in
yesterday's presentation
um one of the examples of the b raft
drug i think it was for a bladder cancer
where in dogs it was having a dream it
sounded like a quite dramatic effect a
40
shrinkage rate in adult in
dog bladder cancers we heard the data
for example that contrast with that
where
the epigenetic kind of structures of the
dog brain tumors appear to be completely
different
from pediatric brain tumors they don't
have the h3 mutation they tend not to
have the b raft mutation
that we see in pediatric patients and
yet when they looked at methylation
profiles they appeared to be very
similar
so here again um there look like there's
some cases where transit
you know the kind of translation ability
is going to be possible
in others where it may look like the
same disease but it has a different
driver and how we will use that
to both inform the pediatric as well as
learn the biology i think
is as much an opportunity as a hurdle
absolutely i want to jump in because i
think
you've made an important point but i
what i'd like to encourage people to do
is to
to look at canine cancers in in a
slightly
uh histology agnostic manner
uh i think we've become hyper focused on
histopathology when we should actually
be looking at genomic landscape
um and so the question isn't not always
is osteosarcoma and dogs a model of
osteosarcoma in kids
you know one of the really interesting
things we found in our genomic landscape
interrogation of canine osteosarcomas is
really frequent dmd
structural variants and those are
becoming very intriguing in the setting
of human sarcomas
uh with respect to aggressive biological
behavior not really understanding
how they contribute so you know in many
respects dogs
with osteosarcoma are a model of dmd
structural variants um and so i think
you know that the same thing happened
with kit mutations which received a very
high frequency in mast cell tumors and
dogs
um with these weird internal tandem
duplications which we didn't understand
25 years ago when we found them but now
they're you know
the mast cell tumors are a model of kit
itd
uh not necessarily a model of mast cell
cancer so i think we need to start
looking
now that we understand the genomic
landscape looking at these
cancers in many respects uh
from the standpoint of what their
genomics is telling us the second thing
is that
you know there is a so we're sort of
talking now about genomic landscape and
targeted therapeutics but i think there
are many features of the
of the canine cancers that really
synergize
with those uh features of pediatric
cancers with respect to them really
generally having a lower mutation burden
tending to be cold tumors much more
challenging to use checkpoint inhibitors
and so these are cancers where we can
begin to understand a little bit more
about how
best to modulate the tumor micro
environment particularly when we're
thinking about
macrophage monocyte neutrophil arms like
the innate
anchor that is really proving to be
extraordinarily challenging
uh in some of these cold tumors
so let me go i was just going to say if
i could add you know certainly your
recommendation cheryl to look at things
from
you know a genomics point of view rather
than a
you know pathology specific view aligns
with the trends for tumor agnostic
approvals right for response
immunotherapy agents
um in adults
and not just uh immunotherapeutic agents
but other targeted agents as well and i
think
probably the the best example of uh
of uh the rapid um development
of a targeted drug in both adults
and children uh were the entrac
inhibitors which used
histology agnostic platform if you will
for evaluation and ultimately
approval so um i i think uh
you know cheryl's point uh about looking
at
genomic landscape similarities rather
than
histology location um of
of a tumor and saying that there's uh
equivalence between
the canine and the pediatric is really
uh
excellent and and and that kind of
functional
data would certainly be helpful in
informing
us as to what is or may not be
a relevant target for a pediatric tumor
now thanks greg for raising that that
point and
as we gain more and more understanding
of
not only the genomics of of cancer but
also now the
epigenomics of cancer
i'm certainly aware of large big data
initiatives
on the on the human side maybe carol can
you talk a little bit about
where we are um
on on canine cancers as far as
efforts to to leverage the data that's
emerging
sure i can touch a little bit on that
there were actually some really nice
presentations yesterday about some of
the emerging
data sets and that are are being
structured
in order to fill in the information that
is developing in humans but still i have
some gaps on the canine side
as these um these efforts develop uh
including the integrated canine data
commons at
uh the nci as well as some of the human
efforts
um that are occurring uh
as those develop it will allow us to
better
leverage the data and look for targeted
approaches
where we can find um similarities
in different cancers between pediatrics
or humans
or adults excuse me and uh
in canine cancers so getting this data
set available will allow
pharma as well as other researchers to
target which where are the opportunities
that these dogs with cancer can help
develop drugs for determine if the drugs
have efficacy or
promise in in pediatrics
and at the same time be helping these
dogs which have relatively few options
often if it's a in some of these more
rare cancers
so it's a win-win across the board
so let me uh turn back because of you
know the
the number of opportunities uh that may
present themselves
but perhaps cheryl
can you give an example of
a recent study or a not so recent study
that um really framed for us how
how efficient are some of the challenges
conducting a clinical trial in canines
and how that data actually uh could have
or perhaps was used uh to help inform i
don't know if there are any examples
that come to mind
sure um so you know one of the
the earlier examples what was a drug
called tasernav or palladia that i
worked with which was actually the
sister drug to
sunitniv or sutent and so we actually
worked
with serena uh as sort of a pre-clinical
in a pre-clinical modeling setting in
dogs with cancer particularly looking at
uh as i said before kit mutations uh
these itds as a model of
just hit mutations in people when
sunitniv was being developed
uh really with the intent of showing
that we had on target
activity that we could induce uh tumor
responses and also
trying to develop methods to give the
drug that were less toxic
um so those both of those drugs went on
to approval
uh and so sedan came first a student and
then we got lady we've had
similar efforts more recently with a
drug called selinexer which is made by
carrier farm which was recently approved
for multiple myeloma
there's a comparator basically a sister
drug called birdnexer
which has gone through phase two studies
in
in dogs and so you know these were
parallel efforts where
the initial intent was to use the dogs
to
generate pre-clinical data and it
emerged into
a secondary effort of developing a
parallel drug on on the canine side so
we have you know several examples of
these now
the other thing i wanted to just follow
on is that one of the
one of the advantages we have in
veterinary medicine is that we simply
don't have as many tools
and predetermined ways of doing things
uh that the human side does uh so we are
in the process of really creating those
tools
and pathways and landscapes to make our
studies
much easier to run so for example we're
putting together the smart iacoc
which will really galvanize the
community and allow us to have
one single iacoc approval uh that will
sort of serve as the general approval
for multiple sites
much like a smart irb but since we don't
have
any sort of processes that are
impediments in place it's much easier to
create that
we've created uh e electronic case
report forms
using red cap that the community has has
sort of
engaged in using we have a standardized
now
consent form that everybody's starting
to use so we really brought the
community together
so that as multi-investigator studies
start
uh really emerging to facilitate rapid
enrollment
will use the same tools and same
evaluation platforms
across the landscape which will not only
facilitate enrollment but will
facilitate data analysis
the other thing that we have which is a
little different than the human side is
that
many of our uh patients who are you know
sort of like pediatric patients because
their owners have to consent for them
don't have alternative opportunities for
care
in many cases uh owners can't simply
afford it because of it's
it's just sort of out of their realm or
there are no other options so
we have a really really strong uptake
from our community
uh within the sort of recruitment we
have less competition for studies
uh and more enrollment of patients that
are previously untreated
so um you know one thing
that uh those of us who who've been
doing this a while and
i think that on the pediatric side is
most of us
um risk aversion
um you know when i was in academia i
would say that would be in
you know the motto i would give industry
risk aversion that
they would not would say they wouldn't
want to start studies because in
children because of
a concern there'd be an observation that
could impact development when
i think the reality is it's usually been
an economic decision but nonetheless
risk aversion exists and i would imagine
risk aversion
um exists even when moving a drug into
into the canine realm um
lynn what what are your thoughts and
does that come
up as far as hesitation from your
perspective with industry
launching canine studies and how do we
how do we reassure people as far as how
these events are
potentially viewed sure i've heard
certainly heard that
concern before you know on our end we
work with the companies
early in development as early as
possible and
designing those studies make sure we're
capturing the appropriate information
and if you're capturing that safety
information
um you know even if something happens we
ask you to follow it up and and gain
that whatever information you can from
that event
it's not um for us it's not something
that because one you know event happened
then the product can't be approved it's
just information that goes ahead and
feeds into
how we look at the product on the whole
i have not seen an issue with that
excuse me personally in terms of an
adverse event
than causing you know a problem with the
animal approval
i'd leave it up to to greg as to what
happens on the human side
greg you want to comment from your
perspective as far as how this
might play out well as you well know uh
peter there's a there's always been this
concern
about the adverse event in a child
impacting the development i'm not aware
and going back and looking through
many years worth of of approvals and
applications
of any adverse event uh um in a
child uh impacting the development of
uh of an oncology drug uh so you know i
think
i think um i think the uh i think the
i don't know um that context of
risk aversion uh is is now uh being
eliminated by the fact that uh uh
industry now
has to have a plan to
study a drug early in its
development of course you know if there
are
concerns about toxicity um
that is something uh that uh uh sort of
uh impacts uh
uh decision making uh irrespective of
how relevant uh
uh a target uh might uh might be um
but i think i think given the fact that
uh
adequate protections are generally in
place
particularly for pediatric studies as
required by
federal regulations i think this
risk of adverse events and
the risk of destroying the development
of what might be
an active drug is
purely hypothetical theoretical
and um not something there's uh
any historical evidence to support
thanks so shifting there as well
um we do hear this sometimes from
different
uh pharma groups that may have concern
about
the canine studies having an impact on
the pediatric
uh program and uh the reality though
this actually came up at our previous
pause for a cure symposium and
to the best of our knowledge from
feedback both uh
within industry as well across
regulatory
groups is this has not actually occurred
so while we have to recognize of course
it's a risk anytime we do another study
there's a risk we may some see something
that surprises
us and that's not necessarily a bad
thing sometimes we need to know and we
need to
to drill down on those things but the
reality is that with the canine studies
to the best of our knowledge um we
haven't seen
these types of adverse events actually
having a substantial impact on the
progress
on the flip side it actually oftentimes
uh
mirrors or gives us a good idea of what
might happen and
most of all helps us to anticipate
whether there's going to be efficacy in
the pediatric environment or the adult
environment
yeah i think paraphrasing what i once
heard rick pastner say and this goes
back some years ago
drugs uh don't get approved because of a
rare
serious adverse event observing a child
drugs don't get approved because they
don't work
um and i think i i think that that
that's turning out to be true and
probably can extend uh to canines
um i want to shift back to opportunities
and
i know one of the challenges we face in
pediatrics and i think increasingly face
is you know the era where um we go to a
maximum tolerated dose and that's how we
develop a drug
i think most of us recognize in large
measure we are well past that era
um where we're now looking for
a dose that hits the target and delivers
uh an appropriate pharmacodynamic
measure
um it is challenging however to do um
biopsies and certainly repeat biopsies
and in all patients with cancer and
certainly with children with cancer
what are the opportunities with dogs
with cancer and
maybe andy you want to talk a little bit
about this
about biomarker development
what what opportunities there may be
there
that could help inform pediatric
development
sure so i think you know as you said
there are certain indications
certain patient populations where tumor
tissue is particularly limited
i can think of some you know adult
indications or diagnosis is made by
radiography rather than through a biopsy
right and so in those clinical trials
you know tissue is limiting
so we're certainly working on in our
clinical trials now
to you know include blood collections
for liquid biopsies
and working to figure out you know that
translatability
and how does the tumor look in tissue
excuse me how does the biomarker look in
tissue
versus in that liquid biopsy so i think
it's a matter then
of you know taking those liquid biopsies
you know
into children into various canine models
to understand you know how well they
will work in each of those populations
but it's definitely
something you know of interest across
the industry
right cheryl did you want to add to that
in any way sure so
many of our studies do involve repeat
biopsy because it's relatively easy for
us to do that
um certainly for tumors that are
external
you know tumors that are in the
abdominal cavity or thoracic cavity
present
additional challenges but just to
parallel what was said
we're working very closely with the
broad institute and umass
on optimizing the liquid biopsy approach
using dogs as a model by trying to
answer questions that are
sometimes challenging you know does time
of day matter when you draw the blood
uh does the vein that you drop the blood
from matter does it have to be proximal
to the tumor or does it matter at all
um and so and this usually requires lots
of sequential blood draws which can be
challenging during kids so
um we are really hoping that we can
help optimize not just some of those
fundamental questions but
how to um really assess clonal
hematopoiesis
and other really confounders that can
make blood biopsy challenging we're
developing our own exome panel
to be able to sort of serve as a
diagnostic and sort of monitoring
function and and so you know i think
these are really clear opportunities
where we can synergize with the human
side to remove a novel strategy forward
that will hopefully not only improve our
ability to assess tumors longitudinally
during
evolution uh you know when they're being
when they're being treated to assess for
new mutations new targets but also to
serve as a biomarker for
early recurrence
um you know to circle back
to osteosarcoma
where i think uh a good deal of
collaboration has already
taken place between the uh the the
communities
what what's on the horizon and i'll
throw that out broadly as far as
is there some low-hanging fruit in the
in the clinical trial space in the
research space
um you know we i know others uh
have spoken and and i did yesterday
briefly about some of the challenges of
identifying targets but
are are there opportunities that we
foresee in the next couple years that we
think or
may come to fruition in the canine model
that uh can help
help move this forward i know
carol do you want to start or uh i don't
want to pick on people on that one
because it's not an easy question
yeah that's um it's
certainly the low-hanging fruit would be
the targets
that are currently of interest for
pediatrics which match up to the known
targets
that we already have identified in in
canine and i think cheryl perhaps and
andy can also
comment further on that but as
these additional data sets develop
adam resnick connie summers and debbie
knapp talked yesterday
about the data sets that are being
developed
for both k-9 and human so that we can
leverage those
as we move forward and that will be the
the next set of low-hanging fruit
so let me uh pick on cheryl from here
and see if she can further i
comment on on that um
so you know i think one of the areas
that we're very very excited about it
really represents
an amalgamation of work from many people
uh understanding the tumor micro
environment people like steve dow
who really led this effort as well as
ryan roberts and sort of dissecting
uh how sarcomas metastasized the lungs
and particularly osteosarcoma
we you know and you'll hear about this
later we have some really exciting
data regarding how we're able to now
target that micro environment
and using repurposed drugs and
understand it better using things like
biomarkers the new nano panel that we
have now string panel
to really help advance the
use of those or introduction of those
sort of combination therapies
in the pediatric population and it's
already happening you know some of the
work that's been done
by steve and and and dan regan is now
actually being done in kids based on the
dog work and and so
we're really making this an inverted
process you know where one of the
things i'm very excited about are these
really sort of mini pilot studies that
we do which are really
rapid five to ten dogs if we're not
getting a big hit we move forward
um because we really don't want that
incremental change we want that
fundamental
paradigm shifting therapeutic that's
really going to impact
more than just a fraction of the
population i think that's where we can
move the field forward very quickly
well i want to leave
we have a question from the audience um
dr ryan roberts asks
aside from safety how would a lack of
efficacy
in a canine study affect the approval
process
so i'm going to extend that question i'm
going to first toss it to greg but then
i'm going to ask mark the comment is
how would it affect thinking in industry
um with a negative study but greg from
uh from a regulatory standpoint uh any
any uh red flags there i guess i would
just
uh question or ask for some
clarification about the
uh approval process uh in the uh the
human uh or pediatric setting or or the
or the canine
uh approval you know how would know
thinking about a pediatric study or
pediatric approval
yeah i think i think how it would affect
uh is is probably it would have uh
an impact uh not so much on the approval
process uh as it would uh
on the decision-making with respect to
whether a product should or should not
be
evaluated or be considered for
development
in the pediatric situation
and i and i think uh if there's uh uh
and
i guess it also depends on the um
definition of lack of efficacy
uh you know i think if uh um the
specific uh
um target uh is not uh altered
from a pharmacodynamic perspective
um and the
function of the drug is really in
question
um then i think that would sort of lower
um the interest if you will um in
proceeding to uh pediatric development
and mark what are your thoughts the
unintended consequences you get a
a negative study in in in a
dog clinical trial um is that going to
uh
how impactful do you think that might be
yeah i mean it will have a pact
obviously the
fidelity of of exactly
you know the reason it failed was it a
pharmacokinetic was it a pharmacodynamic
was it a
salvage pathway and are those the now
how similar is the
dog pathways to the the human in terms
of
how much can you use that data as i've
said it's already
a bit of an uphill climb um nudging
leadership towards pediatric studies
that obviously are not going to have a
huge economic
impact on the company and negative data
obviously probably takes a little bit of
wind out of what is already a pretty
tiny sale
so i don't think it would be helpful in
some ways though the race for children
act
kind of will help negate some of that
because
if there's still a sense from the
regulatory authorities that you still
need to study that pathway to meet your
obligations
for an adult indication then
you may be back on the table whereas in
the older systems that might have been
all the justification
they needed to end the pediatric
evaluation at least early on and
consider it maybe later in the life
cycle
of the drug so i mean it's obviously a
complicated issue that's dependent on
multiple factors
but and and it may be a good thing it
may be that the negative results in a
dog
are an opportunity to save a whole bunch
of kids from getting a drug that it
turns out are not going to be effective
one of the things we're trying to do
certainly at bms and i think most
companies have taken this approach
and i think academics are getting more
in line with is
we say that a trial fails and often the
question
is we understand when a trial is
successful because you see the success
but we often don't know why a trial
fails and it therefore makes it hard to
make a decision
about what to do next or instead of and
so one of the things we're trying to do
is build in
um not for the five percent of trials
that are going to be successful but the
95 that are going to be negative
so that we know why it's negative um and
can therefore make an intelligent
decision
about that house how that would affect
future development
whether that be pediatric or adult
well thanks mark well we're at the top
of the hour i i want to thank
all our panelists for our very robust
discussion
certainly thank the organizers for
allowing us to have this session and
perhaps most importantly again thank dan
for telling us all why we're here and
why we have to do this
so with that thanks everyone and enjoy
the rest of this really important
meeting